Carlos Gon veut geler 30 % de sa
rémunération Renault n'échappe pas à la
crise en 2012 le bénéfice net de la
firme a baissé de plus de 15% mais avec
une plusvalue de 924 million d'euros le
PDG de la marque au losange s'est donc
présenté au Technocentre de guillancour
face à des salariés excédés c'est une
provocation pour les salariés de cette
entreprise 30 % de salaire en moins et
on part pas en moins c'est une partie de
son salaire qui est gelé sur les 4 ans
qui viennent si on retirait 30 % au
salariés même du Technocentre ou des
usines on ne pourrait plus vivre selon
le quotidien Les Échos cette somme
avoisinerait les 430000 € mais Carlos
gone resterait assuré de percevoir plus
de 2 million d'euros pour 2012 le
versement n'interviendrait qu'en 2016 à
condition que l'accord de compétitivité
soit validé par les syndicats et
appliqué à la lettre c'est un chantage
c'est même pas une pression c'est un
chantage si vous signez pas l'accord je
ferme des usine c'est carrément du
chantage pour les organisations
syndicales donc la CGT elle refuse ce
chantage elle dit on peut faire de la
compétitivité mais autrement pas avec un
accord comme ça environ 300 salariés
dont des ouvriers et soniens de Lardi
étaient réunis devant l'amphithéâtre où
se tenait la réunion avec Carlos gone
suite à l'annonce de Carlos g les
syndicats ne comptent pas en rester là
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des représentants
CGT de la marque doit se réunir demain à
Paris vendredi 15 février pour envisager
d'éventuelles manifestation la semaine
prochaine